you're standing at this abandoned mine
you can only see maybe two or three
meters in before it's entirely black
but in the kind of haze you can see the
kind of decrepit old bits of
previous mining industry and
overwhelmingly the squawk of all these
bats
their wings beating in the darkness
oh you can hear them and you know what
kind of species are inside
this step is to foodbot and so what
we're doing here is
basically just checking to see if
there's any signs of hunting
yes so you guys are stopping people from
coming here that's your job yeah we
stubbed in exactly
masks on yep masks on
oh my gosh all right let's check it out
i'll slow it
so you can see them right here
wow so there's an entire colony in here
this is the first time in my life i've
been in a bat cave with bats flying
around
my head but also in the knowledge that
bats
contain viruses that are dangerous to
humans especially in places like liberia
where we know ebola came from
or all kinds of viruses that we don't
yet know about
so it really was kind of quite unnerving
oh wow it was
a relief to have chris nearby who was
kind of quite relaxed about the whole
thing
for me because i'm a complete wildlife
geek i think that this is one of the
most beautiful things that i've seen
even though i know that there is this
potential risk
and people want these bats right chris i
mean these are valuable
in many places these are a preferred
food item where people will pay
almost a premium price or something so
this would be a prime
hunting ground for someone to come in
here and just collect a whole bunch
okay and so if you came in here as like
your average poacher
you're not wearing a mask and there's no
real protection
you could easily pick up any kind of it
this is the exact type of almost
transmission scenario where you are
getting aerosolized urine
aerosolized feces but also if you're
killing the bats you're then exposed
directly to their blood as well
wow yes let's walk in a little bit
wow just keeps going
this is absolutely insane
a lot of the old iron ore processing
equipment i'm guessing is that right
and you guys you're look what are you
looking for what have you found what
moses what is that
this is a trap wired it's for
the animals in the forest it was
prepared by hunters
so it means someone brought in here so
poacher came in here and
and yeah set that up as exactly
yes moses and his team find this trap
which
seems to suggest that humans have been
inside
so you have hunters who are staying in
this cave
night after night being exposed to bat
feces
bat urine bat bites there's actually
horseshoe bats
and a type of fruit bat horseshoe bats
are known to be
related potentially to kovid and
also to ebola oh wow oh my god
and we go further and further back into
the depths of the cave
and moses looks down and he actually
sees a whole host of dead bats on the
ground
you can see that the dare want is the
deer but
wow this is insane
there are many many many on this you can
see this the younger one
this is a baby yeah
oh my god this one is probably a
juvenile or sub-adult
this one's definitely a juvenile so
what caused this one today so you almost
wonder if there was some sort of disease
that spread through this community of
bats it would certainly explain why you
have a variety of different age classes
of bats that are all dead in the exact
same spot
it feels like this is something that's
really important to understand
wow and chris is fascinated by this and
it could be that these bats have died of
some kind of virus
it really does feel like we're in a
front line of something unknown
young bats should not be dying basically
not like this
and i think obviously the issue is if
there's a poacher in here
and there's a dead bat and there's blood
or whatever right so that's a problem
so there's probably some sort of disease
exactly
bats were known to be the reservoir of
ebola
it also transmitted to other types of
animals and then was transmitted to
humans
this is the exact way that a new deadly
virus
could start
[Music]
you